hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played yesterday in
the sixth elite chess titled arena it's
a game between grandmaster and routing
and grandmaster magnus carlsen world
chess champion I'm sure you're gonna
enjoy the game as it's quite interesting
and although it's a bullet game one
minute per player with no increment the
game is a surprisingly high quality no
blunders were made in this game and it
features a very nice opening the Czech
Benoni which I'm very fond of so before
we check out the actual game we do have
a nice photo challenge for this video as
this is a game from the sixth leaches
titled arena I thought we would make the
photo challenge a bit somatic so here we
go who is the gentleman in the photo the
t-shirt is a bit of a you know tell but
you know I don't think it will be too
easy for you so there we have it the
best of luck to everyone and now let's
check out the game as as you know across
someone the first for leech has titled
arenas and then he donated the money
back every time and then for the fifth
I'll eat just titled arena I believe the
the first prize was some three thousand
dollars but III think he started playing
the fifth leaches titled arena but he
did not finish it I think he had some
connection issues and then he just gave
up on it it was actually Andrew tank
here with the handle GM penguin I am one
who won this event so for this sixthly
Chester Larina the first prize is $500
so knowing that let's check out the game
andrew has the white pieces and he opens
with the d4 now we're not gonna analyze
it per se since it's a bullet game but
we are going to show the game and check
out some of the ideas Knight to f6 c4 c5
cousin goes for the benoni defense we
have d5 and now not going for east 6
which is the standard modern variation
of the benoni but rather a 5 the Czech
variation of the Benoni or the Czech
Benoni here nice to see three we have d6
and now II for our cousin goes g6
prepare stuffy and I think out of his
dark squared Bishop g3 Bishop to g7
Bishop to g2 and cat
night g2e - andrew has a nice grip on
the f-4 square he wants the castle push
f4 so Knight B to d7 by Carlsen we have
castles and here a six and now a
standard to move when you're playing
against the Benoni Andrew pushes a for
doesn't allow Carson to push b5 and here
it's always it's never an easy task to
find a move for black when playing the
Benoni especially in a bullet game but
Carson goes for the best idea night to
h5 hip he prepared he prepares f5f for
by Andrew and now e captures on f4 we
have for some reason the sound just came
back so sorry about that
after eek after Sun f4 you could play
Knight captures on f4 but Andrew decides
to go for G capture son f4 that creates
a very nice pawn Center and also moves
like ePHI or f5 will be available in the
future but it allows Crosson to go for
f5 himself so it captures an f5 rook
captures on f5 and now Knight to e4 is
an idea here to go for the g4 square
Andrew goes for in Bishop to e3 crossing
was
Knight d2 F 6 we have night the g3
offering a trade of nights here so
cousin accepts this nice capture son g3
H capture son g3 and now Carson does
have to do something about this rook as
g4 is a threat if you don't go for root
2 H 5 or H 5 then g4 will trap the
rockin H on f5 so instead of h5 Crossing
goes for rope to h5 which is the best
idea bush up to f3 attacking the rockin
h5 and knob comes Rock to h3
King to g2 attacking the rook but the
rock is guarded basically in only making
room for this rope to come to h1 h 5 and
here the best idea for white here is the
best of 2 f2 to keep an eye on the g3
pawn or rope to h1 to immediately go for
for the rook exchange
Andrew goes Queen to d2 and now across
and takes advantage of this very nicely
he pushes h4g captures on h4 and now
I to h5 and this is the idea now you
don't have time to capture on it on h5
because if you capture here then Queen
captures on h4 and there is no defense
either Queen to g3 checkmate is coming
or rook to h2 with check that will win
the Queen on d2 and of course the game
so after night to h5 we have looked to
h1 but now rook to h1 is is much too
late
Crossing plays Queen captures on h4 and
now if you capture the rook here then
you get a bunch of characters with check
King moves and now Queen g3 check bishop
here and now simply Bishop captures
twinkle screen captures and III would
check White will be upper piece in a
completely winning game so after Queen
captures on h4 94 was played by Andrew
not allowing Queen g3 as the night is
now guarding the g3 square and here if
you play something like Bishop to a5 to
maybe remove the defender of the g3
square then white will be able to defend
with Queen to f2 and now after Knight
captures Bishop captures rook captures
rook captures and Queen captures white
will be able to to go into an endgame
for example after Bishop to d3 of course
it will still be much better for for
black but you know he will still have to
work for his meal and as it is a blue
game you don't want to allow white any
chances like these so after Knight to e4
Bishop to g4 was played and now the same
idea doesn't apply but there's really
nothing better here for example if you
capture let's say you go for Queen to f2
this was played in the game here cross
and play the Queen captures on f2 but
even bunch of characters on f3 was
sufficient with check because now after
Queen captures you can go rook captures
and after rook captures simply capture
the bishop on e3 and after Knight
captures on d6 what would still of
course try something gets a bullet game
but being down being down a piece a
whole Bishop here you know no chances
for white here so after Queen to f2
Carson simply chose the the simplest way
but also
the strongest idea Queen captures on f2
here Knight captures on f2 was played
and now comes rock to g3 check this is
probably a move that was missed King to
f1 and now rook captures on f3 Knight
can't capture on g4 because it spins so
rook to e1 and now again the strongest
maneuver nigt check checking the king
and forking the rook on h1 king g2
Knight captures we have night captors on
g4 and now comes rope to g3 and after
keen captures rook captures but it was
already in this I believe it was in this
position and move 28th that entry tank
resigned to the game as after captures
captures we have a position where black
is up a whole rook still it's it's a
rockin 8 but it's a whole rook once you
develop it there's no point in
continuing this game and I don't believe
he was even better on time at this
position so yeah after rook to g3 check
he resigned the game and a very nice
victory for Magnus Carlsen I will put a
link to Andrew tanks YouTube channel so
you can check out this game he was
streaming the entire event the entire
two hours of the 6th Alicia's titled
arena so you can check it out you know
with some of his commentary and some of
the other games he played if you desire
so this game starts at 22 minutes and 30
seconds mark I believe but I will also
put a link to it and the minute mark in
the description below so you can just
click on it if you're interested and for
some final standings here are the final
standings of the 6th leaches titled
arena as you can see GM dem salty that
sport which is Magnus car since the 3rd
handle unleashes so what well for as far
as we know then in second place
Jim Rebecca Harris which I believe is
the Grandmaster Daniel narrowed its key
but not sure and then grandmaster 19 not
1996
obviously Game of Thrones fan then we
have iam opera version vincent retires
of Netherlands Baba Ramdev that's our
Chandra and in sixth place
Andrew tank who almost managed to climb
to the first three places but
but he didn't but it doesn't matter as
he won't
fifthly just at arena with the prize
money the highest-ever that Carson kept
donating which was I believe three
thousand dollars but yeah here the first
place was five hundred dollars
microscopes and donated it back so for
the seventh Lee chest Idol arena we I'm
pretty sure we can expect at least $1000
first place so yeah and as as I've heard
G and M salty that sport the constants
third handle already has over one
thousand followers on leeches so you
know I will put a link to the tournament
in the description as well if you know
browse through through some of the games
or maybe you know follow some of these
strong players and also I prepared this
this is a as you can see penguin I am
one and damn salty that sport played
four games in this six liter side arena
Magnus Carson won all four of them and
here you have some statistics from this
game that they've played so penguin made
seven in accuracy seven mistakes zero
blunders and Carson made sixteen
accuracies one mistake and zero blunders
so not bad by both of them you know for
for a bullet game and there you have
learned from your mistakes if you if you
see this button which is a feature on
Lee chest after a play game you can
check out any of your moves and
stockfish 9 will be very happy to point
you in the right direction so there you
have it that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check to my
previous videos see or think all for
watching and like I said all of the
useful links will be in the script in
the description below so feel free to
check them out and I will hide the
person from the photo challenge
somewhere in the description if you know
if no one figures it out so look for it
there so thank you all and I'll see you
soon
tomorrow with the last two games of the
Bobby Fischer series 1970 tournament in
Palma de Majorca so thank you I'll see
you soon